this is a great topic that came up
yesterday during a live stream and it
touches on politics it touches on
finance it touches on economics so let's
let's dive right into it why did the
stock market go way up last Thursday
when the news was breaking 6.6 million
more people have lost their jobs and
have filed for unemployment benefits
because one would imagine that bad
economic news would cause the stock
market to go down not up precipitously
but the opposite happened indeed last
Thursday when the terrible unemployment
news broke stocks went absolutely
skyrocketing for the day and it has
confused a lot of different people and
it's a great opportunity to talk through
many of the different elements that that
are factors here so there's a few
different things going on first of all
if you want you can just write all of
this off as mere speculation by market
insiders right you can argue the stock
market doesn't even really have any
connection to the news of what's going
on within the economy
it's just traders speculating and
pushing stocks up and pushing stocks
down sometimes taking long positions
sometimes taking short positions when it
benefits them and there's just no
meaning whatsoever in market moves
related to what's happening in the
economy now of course there's an element
of truth to that there's no doubt that
hedge funds derivative instruments a lot
of these non-productive financial
mechanisms can benefit from and even
move markets or exacerbate market moves
without being directly tied to some
factual change on a Main Street for the
average person but it's only a piece of
it it's not really a comprehensive
analysis and it lacks some understanding
of some pretty basic economic concepts
now before I jump into this in more
detail there's two things that I should
mention number one any effort to explain
why stocks went up or down on a
particular day is a fool's errand in the
sense that there's no real way to
definitively say here's why the market
was up or here's why the market was down
on any particular day we're doing this
more of as a thought experiment
number two I understand that lots of the
ideas that I'm gonna use today are
partially debunked in the sense that
standard economic theory a rational
actor efficient market economics has
been partially debunked and that is
undeniable but it still is an okay fret
framework as an entry point to start
thinking about some of these things so
all of those disclaimers out of the way
let's now play the game so the first
thing to understand is that the stock
market is supposed to already reflect
future news that we can expect this is a
classic economics term called efficient
markets hypothesis and put very simply
what what efficient markets hypothesis
asserts is that asset prices the price
of the Dow the Nasdaq the S&P 500 it
reflects all available information now
sometimes information is available but
it's about a future event that hasn't
happened yet efficient markets
hypothesis argues information about
future events is also priced into the
stock market
now of course efficient market
hypothesis is one of those things they
teach us early in economics academia and
to some degree it is complete and total
BS it's only sort of true if the markets
really priced in all future information
there wouldn't be any way to make money
in the market and you know eventually
brought to a absurdity eventually the
Sun will expand and engulf the earth and
everybody on the planet will die unless
we move to some other planet if that was
priced in stock markets would be at zero
because we already know that that's
eventually going to happen so again it's
just an idea it's a framework it doesn't
work 100% but as applied to the
unemployment numbers from last week even
though the 6.6 million additional people
filing for unemployment was announced on
Thursday it was expected for more than a
week ahead of time and there were
predictions about the number of millions
of people that would be filing for
unemployment so arguably it was already
priced into the market now that could
explain why stocks didn't crash on the
announcement of unemployment numbers
last Thursday but it doesn't really
explain why stocks actually went up
drastically on that news that doesn't
seem to make sense well that gets us to
layer two of the analyses which is
markets don't like uncertainty even
though there was the expectation of
millions of people losing their jobs but
last week once it was announced the
uncertainty was removed so if you expect
six point six million people to lose
their jobs and then it's confirmed that
six point six million people lose their
jobs you've removed the uncertainty six
point six million plus the uncertainty
of will it be more will it be less is
worse arguably then just knowing it's
six point six million people who lost
their jobs so that could make stocks go
up lastly when you file for unemployment
benefits you start to get money so from
a market perspective what is going to
happen to the companies on the stock
market when you learn almost 7 million
people are going to start getting money
they're going to start getting
unemployment benefits coming in which
they will spend with a lot of these
companies that trade on the stock market
that could cause stocks to go up on the
news of 6.6 million new unemployment
claims and then lastly when you learn
that nearly 7 million more people lost
their jobs meaning around 17 million
people have lost jobs in just three
weeks that's a signal that this is bad
enough that the government might do more
stimulus and again stimulus injects
money much of which goes to the
companies that are traded on various
stock exchanges so thinking about it
this way we at least have a plausible
explanation for why terrible
unemployment news correlates with the
stock market going up lastly remember
this is more proof that the stock market
going up doesn't mean that Main Street
or the average worker individually is
doing well six trillion and stimulus
could be great in the aggregate for the
market but if the individual person is
getting a $1,200 check
seven weeks after they've been sitting
at home or whatever the case may be it
may be more like five weeks in some
cases you can very quickly see how
aggregate market stimulus can be very
good for the stock market but not that
good for the individual person who has
way more than twelve hundred dollars in
bills overdue and is just now getting
their $1200 check let me know if this
type of segment is useful or interesting
and you know I try to explain this is
the economic concept it's partially BS
right I mean a lot of standard economics
is partially BS but it can still serve
to be useful in thinking about a
particular news event in this case bad
unemployment news combined with the
stock market
going up